[Music]
partings are all about the sweetness and
sorrow but few things are more delicious
than reuniting with your witchy sisters
after centuries apart still after
leaving Salem behind for over 300 years
I couldn't help but Wonder did we still
have the town under our spell or was
there a chance the old magic was truly
gone
[Music]
I mean Hocus Pocus
journey to Salem Massachusetts a town
famous for killing 20 women out of
religious paranoia but it turns out they
were 100 right
not only are witches real but they are
fabulous
in this holiday campfest that puts the
evil in baudeville and imagines what it
would have been like if the Three
Stooges made a Halloween special
wait they did
a whole bunch of them
well what if they were ladies
[Music]
return to the early 90s a time when
other much better Halloween movies were
happening I am the Pumpkin King and
other much worse ones
and meet the Sanderson sisters there's
Winifred played by the legendary Bette
Midler's two front teeth Sarah played by
Sarah Jessica Parker's vagina without
dance with me hang him on a hook and let
me play with him no boys will love me
I'll be my friend who are they boys oh
and Mary she's like their dog or
something
300 years after being lynched by
salamites they've got a plan to get
their group back by killing all of the
town's children go off Queens in this
classic tale that will be remembered as
one of the darkest films in Disney
history
[Music]
call people ugly if it weren't already
one of the most horny films in Disney
history Max lecture yeah in fact
I mean seriously it's obsessed with this
15 year old boy's virginity my brother's
in Virginia are you a virgin yeah
really and he's a virgin a virgin
with the candle Imagine
That by a virgin on Halloween night some
Airhead virgin might light that candle
Brave Little virgin Who lit the candle I
had to wait 300 years for a virgin to
light a candle I mean everyone in this
film is horny to convey gorgeous
creatures such as yourselves to your
most
forbidden desires you think that's not
an eyes wide shot party going on back
there this married couple is played by a
real brother and sister I'm telling you
man this film is for freaks
watch these three golden ghouls do
battle against three neighborhood
children who you unfortunately have to
watch as punishment I want to go home
it's your home now so get used to it
until the movie gets back to the witches
did you miss me listen to armed with the
power of the necro number knock off
these sisters will throw around obscure
curses twist the bones and in the back
and also obscure curses all right your
little trolley mom his punishment must
be more wholesome
curses while still getting repeatedly
beat down by small children
in a Halloween movie that's never
particularly scary except when they run
over a cat whoa whoa speed bug oh dude
that's fine I hate it when that happens
but that won't stop everyone from
screaming at the top of their lungs all
the time
hey
okay
that's enough
[Music]
done yet I am cold
Please wrap it up
nope still screaming
I'll just go wait in the car
so before you check out the sequel on
Disney plus that spend so much time in a
Walgreens you'll swear it's an extended
Super Bowl ad
take a trip down memory lane where
Studios put comedy films in Real
Theaters shot on relocations with Rio
song and dance numbers instead of
throwing Bette Midler in front of a
green screen to fill the Disney plus
content quota for Q3 I give up tired
really whatever good enough next
starring The First Wives coven hex in
the city Sister Act smacking The Habit
virgin General thoris Prout girl next
boar for Sona non grata Jay and violet
Bob and his name is Billy butcher just
like mine are you having a [ __ ] off
diabolical
The schlucky Horror Picture Show
wow Max really leaves his boys behind to
die look man I know they took your shoes
and all but what are you gonna say to
their parents at the funeral
Factory Binks the talking cat what are
you doing here what do you mean what am
I doing here you invited me to read the
comments all right here we go I want
chicken I want liver Meow Mix Meow Mix
please deliver
I'm not getting paid for this am I Misa
Jar Jar Binks Misa your humble servant I
definitely skipped that trilogy
litter box is empty again someone is
stealing my poop
well I must return to guarding the black
flame candle from Airhead virgins John
you're not in that category are you no
judgment just make sure you cash in your
v card before All Hallows Eve special
thanks to that groupings himself Jason
Marsden check him out in the link below